sounds good Sara so like Sara said the
first step will be to get her changes
into my local repository right now if I
run git log on the master branch I don't
see Sara's commit so I'll need to run
git pull and I'll pull from the origin
remote and the master branch recall that
if I wanted to take another look at
Sara's changes first I could run git
fetch examine the changes and then run
git merge Origin slash master master but
since I already know what her changes
are I ran git pull instead now I want
these changes to be incorporated into
the different oil branch so I'll run git
checkout different oil and then get
merged master different oil as expected
I get a merge conflict I'll resolve the
conflict keeping both of our changes so
now there's three quarters of a cup of
canola oil and then I'll commit the
merge now I'll run git log and I can see
that this branch contains both of our
changes here's where the more oil pull
request was merged and here's the merge
commit that I just made now go ahead and
repeat these steps in your own
repository in order to get Sara's
changes to appear in your fork you'll
need to download and run the code we've
provided in the downloadable section
there are instructions on how to do this
in the instructors notes now this code
won't actually make a pull request so
you won't see a pull request appear in
your repository instead if you look at
your commit history on github you should
see a commit that looks like this one
saying merge pull request and you should
also see Sara's commit adding more oil
so the cake is moist once you've run the
code to simulate Sara's changes update
your local repository with Sara's
changes and merge your master branch
into your different oil branch like I
did finally push your different oil
branch to your fork to update your pull
request which I haven't done yet
once you're done here are some things
you can check to verify that everything
has gone correctly your local master
branch should contain Sara's changes
your local different oil branch should
contain the merge commit merging Sara's
changes into your branch the same merge
commit should be visible on your pull
request and the merge button on your
pull request should be green check these
boxes once these things are true for you